jetzt ist es beschlossen deutschland
wird ab spätestens 2038 keine kohle mehr
abbauen und verfeuert hin und her wegen
eines formfehlers im neuen gesetz sollen
die härteren strafen für raser erstmal
nicht mehr gelten
38 grad in sibirien die hitze fach
tausende waldbrände an mit folgen für
unser klima
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers und nahm den allen an
diesem freitag wir haben den
nachrichtenüberblick für sie und katja
stresow kümmert sich um den sport das
mache ich sehr gerne schönen guten abend
bevor die politische sommerpause beginnt
sind heute gleich eine ganze reihe von
gesetzen und vorhaben beschlossen wurden
die erheblichen einfluss auf unser land
und unsere gesellschaft haben
das steht im mittelpunkt dieser sendung
wir beginnen mit dem kohleausstieg denn
nach langen diskussionen jetzt
beschlossene sache ist
bis spätestens 2008 und 30 werden alle
stein und braunkohlekraftwerke in
deutschland stillgelegt wenn möglich
schon bis 2035
zentraler punkt dabei ist die frage wie
die folgen für deutschlands kohle
regionen abzufedern sind diese regionen
gibt es in vier bundesländern darunter
die lausitz in brandenburg und das
rheinische braunkohlerevier in nordrhein
westfalen
für sie wird es rund 40 milliarden euro
an hilfen geben und auch die
energieunternehmen gehen nicht leer aus
sondern werden mit insgesamt 4,35
milliarden euro entschädigt wenn ihr
hier schon berichtet
es ist ganz schön was los an diesem
vormittag draußen protestieren
klimaaktivisten der kohleausstieg könne
und müsse schneller gehen als der der
drin und beschlossen wird
drinnen gibt es plötzlich zweifel bei
der abstimmung hat die koalition die
mehrheit oder nicht dann ist die
logische konsequenz hammelsprung
hammelsprung alle raus aus dem saal
durch drei türen wieder rein eine für
jahr eine vereine für enthaltung der
kohleausstieg geht glatt durch aber
etwas anderes schief an die
abstandsregeln halten sich nicht alle in
der debatte zuvor waren die inhaltlichen
distanzen klarer die bundesregierung
lobt ihre entscheidung als
wirtschaftlich vernünftig
sozialverträglich dass fossile zeitalter
in deutschland geht mit dieser
entscheidung unwiderruflich zu ende
der ausstieg soll bis 20 38 kommen zu
spät kritisieren die grünen
und obwohl sie immer für den
kohleausstieg gekämpft haben für diesen
stimmen sie nicht mit es wäre der tag
gewesen die klimakrise mit der werbe und
entschlossenheit zu bekämpfen
wie die krone und das machen sie dich
mehr zustimmung gibt es für die
milliarden-hilfen für die reviere in ost
und west die jahrzehnte von der kohle
gelebt haben
wir wollen erst die neuen arbeitsplätze
und dann den kohleausstieg wir wollen
nicht dass menschen sozusagen um den
bergmann wirkung zu bleiben ins
bergfreie fallen und keine perspektive
mehr in der region haben gesetze
beschlossen umweltschützer aber wollen
weiter protestieren
heute ist der tag an dem politischen
streitthemen abgeräumt werden die die
politik lange beschäftigt haben
nächstes beispiel das lobby-register
union und spd haben sich jetzt darauf
geeinigt das ziel mehr transparenz
kontakte von abgeordneten zu unternehmen
und lobbyisten sollen verbindlich
erfasst werden
bei verstößen drohen bußgelder zuletzt
hatten die lobby vorwürfe gegen den
cdu-abgeordneten philipp amthor
schlagzeilen gemacht
für die hintergründe gehen wir nach
berlin teo genannt wie effektiv
in der kontrolle und transparenz kann
denn so ein lobbyregister sein und ich
glaube in letzter konsequenz wenn wir
das erst beurteilen können wenn das
fertige register vorliegt die koalition
hat sich zwar heute im wesentlichen
geeinigt aber so höre ich zwei drei
punkte sind noch immer offen und es soll
erst im herbst vorgelegt werden in jedem
fall wird ein solches lobbyregister eine
disziplinierende wirkung haben denn dann
fällt das licht der öffentlichkeit in
einem bisherigen graubereich und
offensichtlich haben union und spd eine
lösung gefunden die einerseits mehr
transparenz herstellt ohne andererseits
den ja auch notwendigen kontakte zu
abgeordneten zu erschweren
ganz wichtig dürfte sein bei
zuwiderhandlungen sollen künftig
bußgelder drohen und das kennt man ja
aus dem normalen leben für die
einhaltung von regeln ist das manchmal
äußerst hilfreich theo koll seit der
berlin dankeschön und noch ein großes
thema im parlament und bundesrat wie
soll es weitergehen mit der tierhaltung
in deutschland der bundestag fordert von
der regierung jetzt ein umdenken eine
neue strategie mehr tierschutz etwa
durch mehr platz für schweine im stall
konkreter wird der bundesrat der
beschluss die umstrittene haltung von
muttersauen in engen metallgittern soll
ein ende haben andreas künast bewegen
unmöglich kein vor kein zurück kein
umdrehen der sogenannte kastenstand gilt
tierschützern als eine der quelle
rishton haltungsformen der
intensivtierhaltung es ist ein
zeitlicher zufall aber ein vielsagender
dass der bundestag heute ganz allgemein
mehr tierrechte fordert während der
bundesrat heute ganz konkret etwas tun
könnte die abschaffung des kastenstand
steht auf der tagesordnung aber
beschlossen wird ein kompromiss
also für die schweine verbessert sich in
zehn jahren etwas bis dahin erst mal
nichts und in zehn jahren werden sich da
zehn wochen nur noch fünf wochen nur
noch in anführungsstrichen in den kasten
stand gesperrt
lasst die sau raus was für die
tierschützer vor dem bundesrat viel zu
lange dauert ist für die landwirte ein
gangbarer mittelweg nicht nur weil der
preisdruck in der schweinemast enorm ist
unsere stelle die betreiben die oft über
jahrzehnte über familien generationen
hinweg
und da sind solche gravierenden
änderungen nicht von heute auf morgen
umzusetzen
zehn jahre zeit für den umbau der
schweinehaltung und acht jahre für den
umbau der stelle
dass ausgerechnet der grüne
agrarminister aus schleswig holstein
diese schonfrist mit ermöglicht setzt
die bundespartei unter
rechtfertigungsdruck
acht jahre ist lang es hätte von mir
jetzt auch ein paar jahre schneller
gehen können aber wenn man schon
längerer zeit gibt dann für einen
kompletten system umbau und der erst
erkämpft worden gegen den widerstand der
cdu damit die landwirte den
systemwechsel überstehen schlägt die
politik eine tierwohl abgabe vor
denkbar wären 40 cent pro kilo fleisch
unser nächstes thema rauchen ist oft
tödlich etwa acht millionen menschen
weltweit sterben jährlich an den folgen
von tabakkonsum
doch im gegensatz zu vielen anderen
ländern gehören genüsslich rauchende
menschen auf plakaten oder litfaßsäulen
in deutschland zum alltag
das wird sich ändern der bundestag hat
heute ein weit reichendes
tabakwerbeverbot beschlossen
außenwerbung wird ab 2022 verboten in
kinos ist im kommenden jahr tabakwerbung
nur noch erlaubt wenn der film ab 18 ist
und auch für e zigaretten gibt es bald
strengere werberegeln details jetzt von
cornelia schiemenz es trifft vor allem
die kinos monate lang waren sie wegen
corona geschlossen jetzt ein
tabakwerbeverbot ab 2021 bittere zeiten
für alle kinobetreiber die um
werbegelder fürchten
es ist schade wir können gerade jetzt
durchaus sehr schöne image bot aber wir
sehen natürlich auch den
gesellschaftlichen wandel die sorge um
gesundheit gerade jetzt und in dem sinn
trifft und sieht sich unvorbereitet
tabakwerbung in kinos auf plakaten auf
parteitagen ein vermeintlich cooles
lebensgefühl wird transportiert
junge menschen sollen so schon
frühzeitig zum rauchen animiert werden
das einstiegsalter liegt in deutschland
bei knapp 15 jahren
damit soll schluss sein nach jahrelanger
blockade hat die union in einer
nächtlichen sitzung einem umfassenden
tabakwerbeverbot zugestimmt
ein jugendlicher der mit werken in
berührung kommen wird wird doppelt so
häufig zur zigarette ab 2024 soll auch
die außenwerbung für e zigaretten
verboten werden e zigaretten aus sicht
der tabakindustrie die weniger
schädliche alternative für die man auch
künftig gerne weiter werben würde
deshalb ist es so bedauerlich dass cdu
csu und spd als neue verbots parteien
diesen weg zu gemacht haben das ist eine
falsche politische entscheidung die
tabakindustrie hält das neue gesetz für
verfassungswidrig und prüft nun den gang
vor das bundesverfassungsgericht in
karlsruhe noch eine wichtige
entscheidung im parlament sie soll den
persönlichkeitsschutz bei fotoaufnahmen
stärken
künftig gilt wer unfalltote fotografiert
oder filmt begeht eine straftat
es droht gefängnis bis zu zwei jahren
und die gleiche freiheitsstrafe kann
auch verhängt werden wenn man frauen in
der öffentlichkeit heimlich unter den
rock fotografiert das sogenannte ups
körting
so viel zu den parlamentsentscheidungen
heute im kampf gegen das corona virus
wollen wissenschaftler jetzt
herausfinden wie viele menschen sich in
deutschland insgesamt tatsächlich schon
angesteckt haben
bei dieser antikörper studie sollen
65.000 blutproben entnommen werden
verantwortlich ist das helmholtz zentrum
für infektionsforschung
die teilnehmer werden bundesweit nach
dem zufallsprinzip ausgewählt sven glas
und simon franz alt waren beim start
heute in reutlingen dabei
es sind nur neun milliliter blut aber
die können helfen eine ganz
entscheidende frage zu beantworten wie
viele menschen hatten schon corona und
sind jetzt möglicherweise immun
andreas seifert ist einer von 65.000
probanden die jetzt bundesweit
untersucht werden
freue ich mich dass ich dazu eingeladen
wurden zu wissen wie viele leute schon
kontakt hatten mit den roma virus bisher
gibt es dazu zu wenige daten deswegen
wollen die forscher nun in zehn
landkreisen auf corona antikörper testen
die finden sich im blut derjenigen die
bereits mit dem virus infiziert waren
die probanten sind zufällig ausgewählt
das ergebnis soll repräsentativ für die
gesamtbevölkerung seien
wir gehen davon aus dass wenn jemand
eine infektion durchlaufen hat dass
dieser mensch dann immun ist für eine
gewisse zeit was wir leider nicht wissen
wie lange diese immunität anhält und
auch da wird unsere studie zu beitragen
deshalb soll in einigen monaten erneut
getestet werden
außerdem ermitteln die wissenschaftler
weitere merkmale der probanden haben sie
vorerkrankungen welchem beruf gehen sie
nach wir hoffen auf diese art und weise
die person identifizieren zu können die
unter besonders hohem risiko stehen die
personen identifizieren zu können
die vielleicht am ehesten auch eine
impfung bekommen sollten wenn dann eine
impfung zur verfügung steht
doch schon bevor es einen impfstoff gibt
soll die studie handlungsempfehlungen
für die politik liefern wie die pandemie
effektiv eingedämmt werden kann ohne das
öffentliche leben zu sehr einzuschränken
mit ersten zwischenergebnissen rechnen
die forscher in etwa zwei monaten die
zahl der korona neuinfektionen in
deutschland bleibt stabil
im schnitt der vergangenen sieben tage
haben sich hier täglich 430 menschen neu
mit dem virus angesteckt genauso viele
wie gestern gegen coop mit 19 gibt es
noch kein wirklich umfassend wirksames
medikament die meisten hoffnungen ruhen
auf fremde sie wir ursprünglich gegen
ebola entwickelt haben studien gezeigt
dass das mittel aus den usa zumindest
die genesungszeit beschleunigen kann
die eu-kommission hat den wirkstoff
jetzt für die coop 19 therapie in europa
zugelassen und welche medikamente sonst
noch gegen cockpit 19 helfen könnten
erfahren sie in unserer zdf
heute app und was genau bei einer
infektion im körper passiert das alles
erklären wir in einem interaktiven 3d
modell jetzt noch frankreich wo
präsident emanuel marco seine regierung
um bildet der schritt war schon etwas
länger geplant makros umfragewerte sind
nicht die besten und dann schnitt seine
partei auch noch am sonntag einem
miserabel ab bei den kommunalwahlen
premierminister edouard phillipe trat am
vormittag mit seiner kompletten
regierung zurück am frühen abend übergab
er sein amt an seinen nachfolger den
song gast ex ein konservativer karriere
beamter thomas walther ist unser
korrespondent in paris thomas soll das
jetzt so eine art befreiungsschlag für
den präsidenten seien ganz genau das
womit 19 hat markus reformpläne in
frankreich gestoppt und die
arbeitslosigkeit und die öffentlichen
schulden zahlen in die höhe schnellen
lassen
und darum brauchte man nun diesen
symbolträchtigen neustart und mit yorker
sex hat er jemanden gefunden der bislang
nicht bekannt geworden ist durch eigene
ideen und durch eigenen machtanspruch
sondern das ist jemand der bislang
wacker und geräuscharm und effizient
politische vorgaben umgesetzt hat und
genau das soll er nun weiter tun
zuletzt war hat er die kurve 19 krise
gemanagt nun soll verhindern dass mit 19
dieses land weiterhin schädigt und er
soll von markus reformen retten was zu
retten ist und ganz nebenbei kann man
kommt damit ein anderes kleineres
problem lösen nämlich dass der
premierminister beliebter ist als er
selbst genau das war zuletzt bei duo
philipp der fall thomas vielen dank nach
paris ein wichtiges urteil aus der
türkei ein istanbuler gericht hat den
deutschen menschenrechtler peter stolzer
freigesprochen
mehrere mitangeklagte bekamen dagegen
haftstrafen
vor drei jahren war der deutsche bei
einem workshop zusammen mit anderen
aktivisten festgenommen worden
der vorwurf unterstützung einer
terror-organisation steudtner dürfte zu
beginn des prozesses die türkei
verlassen und ist jetzt in deutschland
sein fall hatte die türkisch deutschen
beziehungen schwer belastet
bei der commerzbank gibt es offenbar
großen ärger in der chefetage bank-chef
martin zielke hat seinen rücktritt
angeboten
auch der aufsichtsratsvorsitzende stefan
schmittmann will seinen posten räumen
die bank hatte zuletzt rote zahlen
geschrieben es gibt berichte über einen
drohenden abbau von arbeitsplätzen jetzt
ein thema das viele autofahrer
aufhorchen lässt die neuen schärferen
regeln über fahrverbote für raser sind
möglicherweise so rechtlich nicht
zulässig das bundesverkehrsministerium
fordert die länder auf den aktuellen
bußgeldkatalog auszusetzen und wieder
den alten anzuwenden
die folge viele länder teilen die
bedenken machen die rolle rückwärts und
schon herrscht bundesweit verwirrung was
gilt denn jetzt christian decker gleich
am ersten tag als die neuen regeln in
kraft getreten sind hat es torsten
rieken aus hamburg erwischt 88 km/h
schnell wohl nur 60 erlaubt waren
damit droht ihm ein einmonatiges
fahrverbot
heutzutage wenn du bei denen autos
zwischen 60 und 80 stundenkilometer
fährt das ist ja kein großer fühlbare
unterschied für den fahrer
das ist schon heftig seit ende april
sind schärfere vorschriften in kraft die
bußgelder und fahrverbote betreffen ein
fahrverbot kassierte bisher wer
innerorts 31 km/h zu schnell war nun
schon ab 21 km h außerorts bisher ab 41
km/h nun schon ab 26 km h zu schnell zu
hart sagen viele
nun dürfte ein formfehler in der
verordnung die regeln wieder rückgängig
machen
die verordnung sei deshalb nämlich nicht
ich so die meisten experten
die bundesländer müssen auf die neue
situation reagieren geht zunächst einmal
nicht darum etwas rückgängig zu machen
sondern es geht vor allem darum
rechtsklarheit auch zu schaffen
wir stehen vor allem für mehr
verkehrssicherheit aber soll auch
verhindert werden dass die gerichte und
die bußgeldbehörde jetzt unnötig mit
widerspruchsverfahren und weiteren
verfahren überzogen werden
das wird in den ländern nicht ganz
einheitlich gehandhabt viele kehren erst
mal zu den alten regeln zurück alle
autofahrer denen nach den neuen regeln
ein bußgeld oder fahrverbot droht
sollten jetzt handeln
sagen anwälte im moment raten wir gegen
so gut wie alles einspruch einzulegen
es ist vollkommen klar dass die fahrer
bus regelung nichtig sind
nun ist die politik am zug
bundesverkehrsministerium und
bundesländer müssen sich verständigen um
neue regeln zu verabschieden
sibirien wird im moment von einer
hitzewelle heimgesucht und von
verheerenden waldbränden das ist ein
thema das uns alle interessieren sollte
denn gerade in sibirien geht es
besonders schnell mit der erwärmung der
erde und das hat schlimme folgen für die
natur die katastrophe spielt sich im
osten von russland ab mehr als 4000
kilometer von moskau entfernt begünstigt
durch rekord temperaturen von 38 grad
entzünden sich an immer mehr stellen die
wälder und der permafrostboden beginnt
zu tauen was das bedeutet zeigt
christian sie wenn der boden weich wird
und nach gibt passiert dass hier immer
wieder häuser gebaut auf eigentlich
immer gefrorenem untergrund sacken in
sich zusammen russlands permafrostböden
tauen immer mehr auf der eisige tresor
gibt plötzlich pflanzen und tiere aus
längst vergangenen zeiten frei darunter
sogar mut wenn es taut beginnen die
mikroorganismen die bakterien zu
arbeiten und diese organischen stoffe zu
verarbeiten dabei werden sehr viele
treibhausgase freigesetzt in erster
linie kohlendioxid methan sowie
stickstoff dieses jahr ist etwas anders
merken nicht nur die wissenschaftler der
winter war milder als sonst und der
sommer hat schon jetzt rekord
temperaturen über mehrere wochen
gebracht dazu gewitter trockene
waldboden nahrung für die unzähligen
feuer die sich gerade durch die wälder
in sibirien und ost russland fressen wie
hier in jakutien 969 feuerwehrleute und
93 fahrzeuge wurden mobilisiert um die
situation zu überwachen sind auch
fluggeräte des katastrophenschutzes im
einsatz
in vielen regionen wurde der
ausnahmezustand verhängt
oft wird gar nicht mehr gelöscht zu
teuer die brände zu abgelegen
die brände in sibirien spielen eine
recht große rolle in der welt sie
verstärkten nicht nur die klimaerwärmung
sondern beeinflussen auch den
sauerstoffgehalt in der atmosphäre
das klima hat sich ganz stark verändert
sagt der wissenschaftler
wenn das so weitergehe werde es noch
mehr veränderungen und noch mehr brände
geben das wird mich unser letzter
beitrag gewesen sein
zu diesem thema jetzt machen wir in der
sendung den sport katja es ist soweit
die tinte ist getrocknet louisan ist
jetzt offiziell ein münchner
der 24 jährige der zuletzt zuletzt bei
manchester city in der premier league
spielte erhält einen fünfjahresvertrag
beim fc bayern eine unterschrift für die
bayern münchen angeblich 49 millionen
euro locker gemacht haben soll
sané peilt mit dem neuen klub große
ziele an jeder wird oder träumt von der
champions league und deswegen ist
natürlich auch ein ganzes große
gesundheitscheck bestanden endlich hat
bayern seinen wunschspieler
nachdem der wechsel im vergangenen jahr
geplatzt war luisa nie weiß wo das tor
steht in der nationalmannschaft und bald
auch bei bayern münchen morgen morgen
haben großen dfb pokal samstag ist dann
natürlich noch nicht spielberechtigt
wenn die bayern auf bayer leverkusen
treffen die partie am abend im leben
olympiastadion in berlin
meisterschaft der zwanzigste pokalsieg
das ziel verfolgen die bayern mit
nationalspieler niklas süle der nach
kreuzbandriss im oktober in berlin
wieder mittrainiert klar ist natürlich
auch dass wir und dass wir alles
versuchen dass wir das das tobel auch
wieder nach münchen holen
bei leverkusen steht kai wirtz im
blickpunkt der wechselwillige jungs da
könnte mit einem titel seinen marktwert
steigern
die meisterinnen aus wolfsburg streben
im finale in köln ihren sechsten
pokalsieg in serie gegen essen an
das wäre ein rekord an erster stelle
steht der titel an sich und deswegen ist
das das ziel und auch das was wir vor
augen haben
ob in köln oder berlin erstmals gibt es
keine zuschauer beim dfb pokalfinale
aber heute gab es die ersten freien
trainings in der formel 1 zum großen
preis von österreich aber auch dort vor
leeren rängen in spielberg
und es dominiert mal wieder die mercedes
im neuerdings schwarz lackierten boliden
war lewis hamilton schnellster vor
teamkollege valtteri bottas
sebastian vettel fuhr im ferrari die
viertbeste zeit und sprach davon dass
ein wechsel nach der saison zum mercedes
für ihn eine option sei mercedes selber
aber sagt er hat nach wie vor nur
außenseiter-chancen katja vielen dank
ich habe es noch einen gelben zettel da
steht das wetter drauf für die einen
trüb und regnerisch für die anderen
sonnig und sehr warm das wetter am
wochenende sortiert gleich im detail
katja horneffer ich empfehle ihnen das
heute journal mit dem kollegen claus
kleber um 22 uhr und morgen freut sich
hier barbara hahlweg auf sie vom
gesamten heute team danke fürs große
interesse machen sie sich einen
angenehmen freitagabend
[Musik]
meine damen und herren das wetter am
wochenende wird ganz unterschiedlich da
gibt es eine windige wässrige wetter
variante und eine sonnige sommerliche
sommerferien variante
das konnten wir schon heute in europa
beobachten denn in großbritannien gab es
zum beispiel dicke regenwolken bei nur
20 grad die hingen zusammen mit dem tief
verena über spanien portugal dagegen
gibt es ein großes hoch dass es da so
winfried bringt viel sonnenschein und
temperaturen über 30 grad was wir auf
diesem satellitenbild auch schön sehen
können sind die gewitter hier über
italien das sind diese kleinen weißen
kleckse keine gewitter gibt es heute in
dieser nacht bei uns höchstens etwas
regen an der nordsee
sonst ist es oft klar bei 16 bis 9 grad
dazu weht an der nordsee schon ein
kräftiger wind und starker bis
stürmischer wind den gibt es morgen auch
dort da fällt viel regen und die
regenwolken ziehen im laufe des tages
ein bisschen weiter nach südosten
aber hier zwischen berlin und dem
saarland da scheint häufig die sonne und
an der donau sogar strahlend
entsprechend unterschiedlich sind morgen
die höchsttemperaturen liegen zwischen
19 grad an der nordsee und 28 grad in
der lausitz und sonntag ändert sich
wenig am montag gibt es einige schauer
aus den alpen heraus schönen abend noch